madame la Première ministre a écouté à
l'instant monsieur Véran il est
nécessaire et peut-être utile de répéter
deux fois une citation d'Emmanuel Macron
je cite donc dans le principe un
ministre doit quitter le gouvernement
s'il est mis en examen il ajoutait en
avril le principe le principal danger
pour la démocratie et la persistance de
manquement à la probité parmi des
responsables politiques le président
Macron a conservé cette conduite six
semaines entre mai et juin 2017 le temps
d'obtenir une majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée nationale depuis les
affaires se succèdent à un rythme
effréné la banalisation est maintenant
de mise allant même jusqu'à la
nomination au gouvernement de personnes
lourdement accusées la République
exemplaire est de devenue la République
des affaires cette semaine un nouveau
cap a été franchi avec hormis la mise en
examen du secrétaire général de naizé
une première et le renvoi du garde des
sceaux devant la Cour de Justice de la
République une première également alors
madame la Première ministre connaissant
la probité qui est la vôtre
enfin l'appliquer à votre gouvernement
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le Président Gontard comme j'ai
eu l'occasion de le dire à l'Assemblée
hier j'ai pris acte de la décision
rendue lundi de renvoie d'Éric
Dupond-Moretti devant la Cour de Justice
de la République comme chacun ici je
suis attaché à la séparation de
l'exécutif du législatif et de
l'autorité judiciaire je ne commenterai
donc pas cette décision en revanche je
veux rappeler deux éléments fondamentaux
pour notre État de droit
le premier c'est l'indépendance de la
justice c'est un des piliers de notre
démocratie et le second c'est la
présomption d'innocence elle aussi
protège chacun elle aussi est
primordiale dans un état démocratique
ces principes n'appellent ni
commentaires ni exception
dès lors une seule question se pose
cette situation affecte-t-elle le
fonctionnement du ministère de la
Justice
ma réponse est claire et elle se fonde
sur plusieurs mois de travail avec le
ministre alors oui le ministère de la
Justice se réforme se transforme oui le
ministère de la Justice avance et voit
ses moyens atteindre des niveaux inédits
oui des réformes profondes s'engagent
notamment suite aux états généraux de la
justice
l'engagement du ministre est résolu
solide et indéfectible et pour les
dossiers ou Eric Dupont-Moretti est un
justiciable comme les autres ou pour
ceux qui la pu connaître en tant
qu'avocat nous avons mis en place un
dispositif de déport il est exigeant il
est efficace il me conduit à piloter en
direct une série de sujets je vous
remercie
je suis le président routard
[Applaudissements]
merci Madame la première Mini je pense
que vous n'avez pas bien compris le
sujet n'est pas ici la présomption
d'isocence le sujet c'est le respect de
la parole donnée qui plus est de la
parole présidentielle le sujet c'est de
ne pas ternir l'image du gouvernement de
la France le sujet c'est de disposer de
ministres à temps plein au service des
Françaises et des Français le sujet
c'est la sérénité qui incombe à la
décision de justice a fortiori quand le
justiciable et le garde des sceaux le
sujet c'est la préservation de
l'indépendance de la justice Emmanuel
Macron nous avait promis l'exemplarité
politique de mise sous François Hollande
mais il nous ramène aux pratiques
délétères des présidents de Jacques
Chirac et Nicolas Sarkozy alors que la
crise démocratique est plus profonde que
jamais alors que l'extrême droite est
aux portes du pouvoir alors que les
fascistes l'ont conquis de l'autre côté
des Alpes la responsabilité qui est à
votre devant l'histoire et considérable
madame la Première ministre il est
encore de temps de prendre la bonne
décision
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]